godzilla vs kong is finally out in the
world and while most people are paying
attention to the eponymous titans the
film has more than just these two
monsters
here are five characters from the film
who are more important than you probably
realize
in the last few years podcasts and
podcasters have increasingly grown in
popularity and as the volume of podcasts
increases so too does the number of
podcasters becoming household names
it seems safe to say that by the end of
godzilla vs kong bernie hayes
played by brian tyree henry is about to
become the most famous podcaster in the
world of kaiju
by the time we're introduced to bernie
he's already dedicated several hundred
episodes worth of podcast time to
exploring the conspiracies behind
monarch and giant monsters
if bernie's podcast was popular before
the events of godzilla vs kong then
imagine how popular he'll be after
playing an active role in helping the
two monsters defeat mecha godzilla
and imagine how informed the public at
large will be about apex and their
shenanigans
and while we're on the subject of giant
robots
there aren't exactly villains in
godzilla versus kong so much as there
are antagonists who think they're doing
something smart
only to wind up hoisted by their own
egomania ren serizawa played by shuna
guri
is one half of a duo of bad guys whose
belief is very simple
in order for humanity to thrive they
must prove themselves to be a stronger
collective apex predator than any giant
monster
the creation of mechagodzilla using the
combined mind of king ghidorah's brain
and the human mind may have failed but
that doesn't mean it will be the last
effort made toward a similar end
and while ren seems pretty dead by the
end of godzilla vs kong that doesn't
mean his story is over
we can always see a prequel story
explaining how ren came to create mecha
godzilla
ren is after all the son of ken
watanabe's ishiro serizawa who has much
more of the opinion that humanity should
play its part in the world by sometimes
standing back and letting the giant
monsters fight
[Music]
let them fight what caused ren to employ
a decidedly opposing tactic not to
restate things but godzilla vs kong is
primarily focused on the stories of two
giant monsters
however nathan lind played by alexander
skarsgard has a backstory way too
important not to flesh out later
when lin is approached by walter simmons
about his potential involvement in
traveling to the center of hollow earth
we get a very brief mention of his past
attempt
what we know is that lin's brother died
in an attempt to get to the kaiju
stomping grounds but we don't really
know how that happened
we don't know why lind is fixated on
hollow earth we don't know how he became
affiliated with monarch and we didn't
see him fall out with the organization
either
that story is at least worth a tie-in
comic but much like ren the other reason
why lind is so important is that it's
his ideas that helped drive the journey
to hollow earth in the first place
it seems likely that lind will play an
important role in understanding and even
benefiting from hollow earth and
forthcoming stories
eileen andrews played by rebecca hall is
the reason king kong stays safe for as
long as he does
she's his guardian in many ways the
containment area kong calls home
exists in part because of andrews and
the safeguards used to keep kong safe as
he travels to hollow earth are a result
of her care as well
when we see hollow earth one of the
things we notice straight away is that
there is even more monster life down
there
and if there is anyone who can catalog
and understand that life it's eileen
andrews
andrews is important for the future of
this franchise precisely because she'll
likely stand opposed to the
destroy all monsters edict of the
antagonists and as she takes on more
power and monarch in the wake of the
story and he attempts to build max will
likely be tempered by andrew's level
head and respect for all of nature's
creatures
including kong all that being said there
is one character in godzilla versus kong
who stands head and shoulders above the
entire rest of the cast
gia played by kaylee hoddle to say that
gia's empathy and ability to communicate
with kong literally saved all of
humanity's collective bacon
is probably an understatement and she's
only going to become more important for
humans and monsters alike both
as she gets older if you recall in kong
skull island the island is home to more
than just the big eight
there's also a tribe of people living
symbiotically with him and while kong
protects those people they also respect
and watch out for him
we find out in godzilla vs kong that the
only surviving member of that tribe is
jia and it's through her ability to use
sign language that humanity learns kong
isn't just
intelligent but also able to communicate
jiya is so in tune with kong that she
can feel his heart slow down to the
point of death
without her he wouldn't even be alive
right now it's hard to say that there's
anyone else who could convince kong to
fight for the human race at this point
other than gia similarly we may discover
that other monsters are able to
communicate through sign language
as she gets older it seems likely that
gia may not only be the person best able
to understand these creatures
she may also be their strongest advocate
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movie moments are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you